it's no secret that over the past decade
warren buffett hasn't been at the top of
his game in fact between 2010 and 2020
he basically just matched the market
this isn't terrible performance given
that most hedge funds don't even match
the market but for a legendary investor
with an average annual return of 20.5
percent it's rather disappointing this
has caused many to wonder if buffett has
lost his touch in the new digital world
despite this lackluster performance over
the past decade
buffett has actually been crushing it in
2022 in fact berkshire hathaway is
slightly positive on the year while the
overall market has been getting
slaughtered currently berkshire hathaway
is up three percent on the year while
the s p 500 is down 16
this recent move means that berkshire
hathaway is officially outperforming the
market not just on a yearly basis but
since the bottom of the 2008 financial
recession which just when you quote
unquote lost its edge so here's the top
5 reasons why buffett has been
struggling to beat the market and how
he's overcoming these challenges
likely one of the biggest reasons
buffett has had trouble beating the s p
500 is due to his focus on value stocks
in recent history value stocks simply
haven't kept up with the growth stocks
in terms of returns between 2010 and
2020 growth stocks almost outperformed
value stocks by a full 100 percent
but while growth stocks tend to
outperform during bull markets they also
get crushed during bear markets and
given that the nasdaq is currently
experiencing a bear market it's not
surprising that many of these high
growth names have gotten destroyed since
the start of the year the growth stocks
in the s p 500 have underperformed
berkshire hathaway by about 25
conversely many value stocks have
performed extremely well such as energy
stocks since the start of the year the
value stocks in the s p 500 have
outperformed the overall index by nearly
10 percent so in the current market
environment buffett's value-centric
investing philosophy is holding up
pretty well aside from benefiting from a
risk-off market buffett has also moved
towards embracing a few high growth tech
companies himself if we take a look at
his holdings we'll see that apple is by
far his biggest position he currently
has 133 billion dollars in apple which
accounts for nearly 40 percent of his
entire portfolio another mega cap
company that buffett has recently
embraced is amazon his take in amazon
isn't nearly as large as his take in
apple but it is still a billion dollar
position buffett has even ventured into
some more early stage tech companies
such as snowflake which isn't even
profitable yet currently these stocks
are actually holding back buffett given
that they're all down by substantial
amounts apple is down 20 amazon is down
34 and snowflake is down over 50
so if buffet is able to post a positive
return with all these tech companies
being down so much imagine what type of
returns he'll be posting when these
companies recover
in the end buffett's willingness to
finally embrace tech while also
maintaining his value positions has
enabled him to enjoy the best of both
worlds
another major issue that buffett has
faced over the past decade is simply
putting his money to work buffett has
been holding significant amounts of cash
which of course produces little to no
returns his cash position has gone
slightly better over the past two years
as it has dropped from 128 billion
dollars to 106 billion dollars today but
there's still a long way to go but wait
a minute why is buffett even having
trouble deploying his cash in the first
place well at the core buffett is still
a value investor and though he has
embraced some growth plays he's not
willing to buy when prices are quote sky
high now you might disagree with the
statement given the recent sell-off but
on a historical basis the market is
still trading for a rich valuation for
example the median p e ratio of s p 500
companies over the past 140 years is
14.89 today the p e ratio of the s p 500
stands at 20.34 which means that the
average company is still overvalued by
33 percent
similarly the buffett indicator which
compares the us stock market with the
u.s gdp suggests that stocks are
currently overvalued by 75
now i'm sure there's gonna be comments
down below that argued that these models
are outdated due to low interest rates
excessive money printing and the rise of
international markets and while you may
be right we have to acknowledge that
buffett is more of an old-school
investor
so i think it's safe to assume that he
gives at least some weight to the
indicator that was literally named after
him alright so the overall market may
seem overvalued from buffett's
perspective but regardless of the market
environment there's always deals on the
market right well there are always deals
on the market but the problem is that
these are generally underrated small cap
companies that won't really move the
needle for buffett for example let's say
he finds an extraordinary small cap
company that's worth one billion dollars
even if buffett bought this entire
company and the company include 10x
within the next 10 years he would only
make 9 billion dollars now that's an
insane amount of money but it would only
grow buffett's overall portfolio by a
mere 2.6 percent considering this
investing in small cap companies is
simply not a feasible option for buffett
he has to stick to companies that are
worth tens of billions if not hundreds
of billions and amongst these companies
it's been extremely difficult to spot a
deal one of the main ways that buffett
has been compounding this issue is by
constantly growing his existing
positions last quarter for example he
bought 600 million dollars worth of
apple stock but this can only take him
so far and sooner or later he's going to
have to find new companies to invest in
as buffett's portfolio continues to grow
and he concentrates on large cap
companies one of the biggest hurdles he
has to face is unintentionally becoming
the market himself i mean if you just
keep adding large cup positions you
basically just become the snp 500
yourself buffett currently has 48
positions in basically every industry
you can think of from tech and retail to
food and banking while this may not
sound like a big deal it is given that
buffet is currently breaking his own
advice
one of buffett's most famous sayings is
that diversification is protection
against ignorance it makes little sense
if you know what you're doing
now i don't think buffett is
diversifying to protect against
ignorance i think he's diversifying in
an attempt to deploy as much capital as
possible but this naturally comes along
with the unintended consequence of
limiting upside potential aside from
breaking his own diversification role
buffet is also actively breaking his 20
slot rule the rule suggests that an
individual's financial success could be
improved if they could only make 20
investments throughout their entire life
the idea is that if an individual's
investment choices are heavily
constrained they would be highly
selective with each investment they make
and hopefully this electiveness would
improve their chances of making good
investments given that buffett is
currently holding on to 48 different
positions he's clearly not abiding by
this role but this isn't to say that
buffett isn't trying his best to limit
diversification
even though buffett has dozens of
positions his portfolio is still
extremely top heavy his top 10 positions
for example account for 85 percent of
his portfolio and his top 20 positions
account for 96 of his portfolio in other
words all of buffett's investments past
the 20 slot roll only account for four
percent of his portfolio despite all of
his efforts though it's only natural
that the performance of berkshire
hathaway gets closer and closer to that
of the market as they continue to grow
and their investments mature
on top of all these external factors
weighing down on berkshire's performance
it should be noted that buffett has made
a few major mistakes himself for example
in the early 2010s buffett wanted to get
in on all the tech growth so he decided
to buy a legacy player which was ibm in
2011 he announced that he purchased 10.7
billion worth of ibm at 170 dollars per
share while ibm did reach about 200 per
share in 2013 he has since been on a
decline and buffett eventually ended up
selling his shares for a loss while this
was no doubt a subpar investment buffett
also made one of the worst investments
of his career within the past decade
which is of course craft heinz while
buffett maintains that both kraft and
heinz are great companies fundamentally
he has admitted that he overpaid for the
craft portion of the business aside from
paying a premium for the company buffett
went on to oversee a merger of the two
companies which hasn't been all that
successful i have a full video on the
downfall of craft heinz if you're
interested but in essence the company
couldn't keep up with the prices of
generic fans or the healthiness of
up-and-coming brands so they've been
stuck in this weird middle ground that
doesn't appeal to either demographic on
top of this craft heinz has been
involved in an accounting scandal
they've had to write off massive losses
and the ceo left during the peak of
their troubles as you would guess all of
these issues have resulted in craft
heinz stock getting obliterated they're
currently down over 50 percent from
their peak in 2017. despite this
horrendous performance buffett has
continued to vouch for kraft heinz but
it should also be noted that he has been
transparent that he would have sold the
stock a long time ago if he was able to
easily liquidate his massive position
fortunately though it does look like
kraft heinz has finally bottomed out and
it's starting to form an upward trend so
hopefully craft heinz won't weigh down
on buffett's portfolio moving forward
while everything we've covered so far in
the video are valid points something
that we shouldn't overlook is buffett's
age buffett is currently 91 years old
this isn't to say that buffett is too
old for this or anything like that but
it does bring up the question how much
does buffett even care about beating the
market anymore when you're over 90 years
old i suspect that you would care a lot
more about living out the last of your
days to the best of your ability as
opposed to beating some vain metric
buffett clearly still enjoys investing
and talking about stocks that's why he
continues to lead berkshire and
regularly participates in press events
but with that being said i think buffett
has several more priorities that are
higher than beating the market like
philanthropy warren buffett is the
biggest philanthropist in the entire
world having donated a massive 42.8
billion dollars and a given that buffett
is looking to donate all of his wealth
after he dies i suspect that his number
one priority is to ensure that all of
his wealth ends up in the right hands
this aligns with what he's been
recommending as well after all buffett
doesn't even recommend that you invest
in berkshire he recommends that you
invest in the s p 500 considering this
it's pretty clear that buffett isn't
exactly trying to appeal to investors
meaning that maximizing returns is not
his top priority at this point it seems
like he's just looking to see how far he
can take it while having some fun and it
just so happens that he's beating the
market once again do you guys think that
this is just some random fluke or do you
think buffett will continue to leave the
market comment that down below also drop
a like if you're a fan of buffett's
insane philanthropy and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch your videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you